welcome back to PlayStation grenade
hello there I'm Adam and it's time to
recap the events in Marvel Spider-Man
from back in 2018. let's do this
this isn't your typical superhero origin
Tale the moment we first see Spider-Man
he's already been the web Slinger for
years with a personal correspondent at
the police department no less the
PlayStation Spider-Man seems to have the
perfect life and in the very first scene
we take down Kingpin after eight years
of trying he's finally going to prison
once and for all and New York is safe
and why not you wish you had me back
the web Slinger's life is all about
balance being Spider-Man while still
living a relatively normal life as Peter
Parker things aren't as great in his
everyday life Peter will likely lose his
apartment soon as the bills are piling
up and eviction looms his love life
isn't great too Mary Jane Watson was his
girlfriend but now they've separated and
this Peter is holding down his dream job
and no he isn't a photographer he quit
The Daily Bugle and is now working with
Dr Otto Octavius to create these
mechanical limbs nothing bad will ever
come of Octavius right not yet now the
Kingpin is behind bars The Daily Bugle
needs a story and that's where Mary Jane
comes in she's a reporter looking for
the scoop surprisingly at fisk's Museum
she stumbles across an old statue that
has a secret compartment within it and
unveils a document about something
called devil's breath before we can
learn more the museum is attacked by a
new enemy known as the demons they take
the document and evade Spider-Man
hello there Peter and MJ reconnect over
dinner until he ditches her to go take
down the Shocker in a pretty epic boss
fight Peter is very close to his Aunt
May who works at a local Feast kitchen a
place for the homeless Peter is often
here to see his aunt and he's built up a
relationship with the owner of the
establishment Mr Martin Lee who so
happens to have a degree in art history
which is a coincidence because Peter
needs him to identify the demon mask
taken from the museum Heist Martin Lee
warned Peter that MJ may be in trouble
if she doesn't drop this story it could
be connected to dangerous people but we
know MJ she has no intentions of giving
this up whilst doing our day job with Dr
Octavius his workplace is suddenly shut
down by none other than Norman Osborne
Peter's best friend's dad who is also
the mayor of the city and it definitely
appears like he's doing this on purpose
to keep his former business partner and
competitor behind him oh and there's an
important plot Point here as Pete's best
mate Harry Osborne isn't in this game
he's supposedly away in Europe right now
after another boss fight again with the
Shocker Spider-Man starts working
closely with the police and his trusted
Captain Yuri Watanabe she directs him to
a fellow cop named Jefferson Davis call
me Jeff
and I'm sure you know this but just in
case Jefferson Davis is the father of
Miles Morales and this line is just
great you remind me of my son started
taking apart the TV when he was five now
he's unlocking his friend's phones
sounds like he could teach me a few
things big Jeff and Spidey with a
warrant in hand search a warehouse to
find the Demon's gangly stealing weapons
a Chase Begins with Jeff and Spidey on
their case and during the kerfuffle
Jefferson Davis saves Peter's life I bet
his son miles is very proud all the
while MJ is still hunting for answers to
that demon story long story short now
Fisk is behind bars the demons are
systematically taking over all his
businesses and territory Peter returns
home after a hard day web slinging to
find out that he has been evicted the
locks have been changed and everything
has been thrown into the trash which
Peter then tracks down the correct
garbage truck and gets his Tech back but
sadly now Peter is homeless and he's
forced to sleep at the feast shelter in
Aunt May's office another cool fight
scene with the demons and the helicopter
and it so happens officer Jeff's son is
watching and he's a huge Spider-Man fan
hey Fanboy little does he know
Spider-Man is a big fan of his dad and
the city now watches as Jeff receives an
award from the mayor of course great
moments like these don't last very long
in the comic book World mayor Osborne
receives a phone call over the coming
days your
City and everything you care about will
be destroyed and people start to go boom
foreign
this is also the first time we play as
miles as Peter recovers from a blast to
the face miles saves his mother and then
hunts for his father
no
we got
Jefferson Davis is laid to rest the
origin story of Miles Morales has
already begun I just wanted to say I
know you're going through
that's what you were gonna say right
Peter is certain Martin Lee is the
leader of the Demons yet Yuri won't act
on this without proof suddenly silver
Sable arrives and she's no second-class
hero here she takes Spider-Man down with
ease luckily Yuri is here to vouch for
Pete it turns out Norman Osborne has
called in Sable and her task force to
protect him from the demons Peter hooks
up miles with a job at the feast kitchen
to help him Escape his grief bad timing
on the TV mate whilst here Peter finds a
secret room in Martin Lee's office
inside we get the answers we need and
the evidence that Yuri needs Martin Lee
hates Norman Osborne with her passion
look at this board we also find files
about the devil's breath but wait this
room is booby trapped designed to
eliminate anyone who finds his Secrets
but Pete is built different while
leaving Martin Lee returns to catch
Peter snooping around but they both stay
calm and as Peter attempts to follow Lee
he can't because he's attacked by his
own friends at feast Martin Lee can
manipulate people corrupting them with
their own thoughts because Martin Lee is
Mr negative Peter continues to live this
double life going back and forth between
work with Dr Octavius and being the web
Slinger around New York the prosthetic
arms Otto and Peter working on are
improving but they're having many
setbacks before they can test this in
real life damn it elsewhere Peter is
trying to get back with MJ but she's
totally driven by her career and the
demon story news comes in that the
demons are searching for a scientist
known as Morgan Michaels we don't know
much but we rushed to a fancy dress
party which he may be at check out my
moves you
Spider-Man is constantly one step behind
and to change this we head to ozcorp to
infiltrate Norman Osborne's company to
find out that devil's breath is a side
effect of something called gr27 the
original gr27 was designed to fix
genetic issues in humans but as tests
continued it became apparent that this
was so contagious that it could cause a
worldwide pandemic hence the nickname
devil's breath to our knowledge there is
only one vial of this stuff and it's
with super scientist Morgan Michaels
back to real life and daytime Peter and
Dr Octavius have excelled at their
neural link limbs revolutionary stuff
right here and Octavius reveals
something about himself my doctors call
it a degenerative neurological disorder
the worst part is it only affects the
muscles all this research was actually
for himself as he's losing the function
of his body and he doesn't want to go
out that way nothing wrong with that bro
hug moment back on the street we catch
up with Miles Morales who finds himself
in a fight with thugs and it so happens
that Spider-Man is around
a touching moment between the two as
miles Fanboys a bit hear The Amazing
Spider-Man Through The Spectacular
Spider-Man a few other choice adjectives
Jameson uses and then gets a free
sparring lesson the location of Morgan
Michaels is revealed and the demons are
already there and attacking his Convoy
they want the devil's breath vile Mr
negative tries to corrupt Peter and we
go into this weird negative dream
sequence but he's too strong and finds a
way out long story short the demons get
away and silver Sable isn't happy but at
least we save Morgan Michaels so devil's
breath is Norman Osborne's fixation he
needs it for something or rather someone
very secret to Norman this isn't a
weapon this is a way to heal time passes
and we don't hear anything for a while
so MJ takes a trip to Grand Central
Station and is kidnapped by Martin Lee
who has used that vial of devil's breath
to make a bomb he then calls mayor
Osborne with an ultimatum I want you at
Grand Central terminal in 30 minutes by
yourself
or there'll be more blood on your hands
are we going to get a bad guy face off
well no because Spider-Man is already
here and along with MJ they disarm the
bomb and save a train full of passengers
the icing on the cake has to be the
capture of Mr negative it's just a
typical day for the duo but their
relationship remains a mess never text
and Twink Peter meets back up with Dr
Octavius and look what has happened
Otto has completed their studies and the
intracranial interface is complete Pete
checks and there's a high probability
that the doc's memory and brain
functions will be impeded imminently
soon dark Arc will take over Otto it's
only a matter of time thank you Peter
for everything and yeah it happened 20
seconds later when the doc sees Norman
Osborne on TV his rage and anger are
taking over
the storyline goes from 1 to 100 now as
the devil's breath vial is stolen and at
the very same time a mass Prison Break
occurs during this action scene
Spider-Man saves Captain Yuri and faces
off with many super villains including
Electro vulture Rhino Scorpion and Mr
negative Peter tries to take them all on
but there's one more villain joining
them the Sinister Six is now complete as
Doc Ock is the leader surprisingly docok
does not kill Spider-Man instead he gets
a warning this is likely because Otto
believes Peter designs Spider-Man's suit
and still has dear feelings towards his
understudy it doesn't stop him yeating
Spider-Man from the top of the raft
[Music]
goes full villain mode and releases
devil's breath over Time Square everyone
will become sick in the vicinity which
means most if not all will unalive in
the next seven days
the city is now overrun Sable
International the police and the escaped
criminals are doing battle city-wide
looting and fires break out one of which
has miles and Aunt May in this perilous
position but don't worry Teamwork Makes
the Dream Work and everyone is okay
Spider-Man then uses Batman style
detective work to track down docock's
new layer but this was all part of the
doc's plan and Ambush begins Electro and
vulture team up but Spider-Man comes out
on top again two of the Sinister Six are
now in custody four to go scorpion
inject Spidey with a neurotoxin and
after a Trippy fight scene Peter makes a
cure because yes science and then wakes
up in his underwear come on we've all
been there Peter also takes this
opportunity to check on loved ones and
realizes that Aunt May is infected with
the devil's breath we need to find a
cure and fast I am fine Peter
just a little run down meanwhile miles
has gone on a daring run to find medical
supplies at Sable compounds and bumps
into these two I apologize
miles doesn't have any superpowers but
escapes all the same with that training
he received earlier on
you want a taste no I'm good kid and
then it's time for another epic battle
this time between Spider-Man and Rhino
and Scorpion
a little forced together time might help
you boys learn to play nice four of the
Sinister Six are now back behind bars
spidey's partnering crime MJ finds a way
to break into Norman Osborne's apartment
to look for Clues and wow does she find
them first bombshell Harry Osborne Peter
and MJ's childhood friend is revealed to
be seriously unwell why didn't you tell
us you were sick and that devil's breath
is being prepared to help him but the
chances of survival are small this
explains Norman's obsession with the
devil's breath he wants to save his son
and never really intended to weaponize
that substance at least not yet
bombshell number two behind the family
portrait of Norman and Harry is a secret
room in here we have gobbling grenades
what are these things
prototype hand grenades this object here
which something living inside and an
anti-serum for devil's breath is
confirmed to be possible and wait
there's another bombshell bombshell
number three confirmation about Martin
Lee's origin it turns out that he
underwent clinical trials at oscop who
kinda accidentally created his alter ego
Mr negative that's why Martin Lee also
hates Norman Osborne MJ overstays her
welcome and just in time she hides from
Silver Sable who bursts in she just
knows when someone's around oh and this
happens we'll talk about that soon after
a short face off with Sable
International she agrees to work with
Spidey to save mayor Osborne she takes
on the riffraff while Spider-Man faces
Lee one on one who is hell-bent on
Revenge
oh
this won't bring your parents back
another bad guy another epic battle with
Spider-Man coming out on top and
claiming the devil's breath anti-serum
five Sinister Six members down just one
to go docock Boston and not only gets
away with the anti-serum he also takes
the mare with him Spider-Man had failed
and I don't think he's gonna get up
again but then there's a stunning scene
with Morgan Michael Sable miles and Co
as they work together to save their
Spider-Man his only thought when waking
is
excuse him
where's me it may be too late for Aunt
May she could pass away any moment and
Peter has a moment of self-doubt I don't
know if I can meet him
maybe you can't
maybe Spider-Man needs help from his
friend Peter
what
Peter helped build those arms remember
if anyone can find a weakness it's him
luckily MJ is there to alleviate that
issue go get him tiger oh and something
totally unrelated happens the spider
that had crawled on MJ's clothing at the
laboratory decides to get off again and
then bites Miles Morales
hmm I wonder what that means but there's
no time to think about that now it's
time for the final battle Spider-Man vs
Doc Ock but this time Peter makes a suit
that will even the odds in the battle
the anti-ok suit
[Music]
the rain paused down Doc Ock ascends the
Oscorp Tower and says goodbye to his
former friend Harry Osborne you're a
failure Otto and you always will be
[Music]
oh
the final battle is the most epic of the
game with Doc Hawk Spider-Man's superior
but there's a moment in this fight that
changes everything
such a disappointment
Parker
you
tried to warn you Peter
you didn't listen
no this means too much to me
not more than it means
is now able to treat Doc Ock as the Real
Enemy rather than the friend he wishes
to save and well see for yourself
if you want to change the world
you have to be the kind of man
who can make the hardest decisions
I couldn't agree
more
without that neural link Doc Ock is no
threat and the two men speak for the
last time I saw you as a son
I should have known you turned on me
just like all the others turn
I've worshiped you your mind your
conscience
wanting to help others the way you never
gave up
you were everything I wanted to be
threw it away
no
if they put me away
they'll take my arms
I'll be trapped in this
useless body
and of course
you rest easy
knowing your secret is safe with me
you do what you think is best doc
it's all any of us can't
be there
even when it hurts like hell you know
where are you going
to be here
this story isn't yet over with the vial
of anti-serium in hand Peter has one
last decision to make does he give the
vial to Morgan Michaels to replicate and
cure the entire city or does he use it
to help the woman who raised him and may
take off your mask
I wanna see my nephew
you knew
I've known for a while I never wanted
you to worry
I did
and I am so proud of you
and Ben would be too
all the people you've saved
I don't know what to do
yes you too
laughs
Peter chooses the greater good and sits
with his aunt until she passes
story on such heartache life goes on the
cure to devil's breath is successful
docock is secured Behind Bars Mary Jane
is now an associate editor at The Daily
Bugle and Miles has something to tell us
to things
he's better than I just um
I show you no no no no
it's pretty weird right
weird right
not that weird there's a second
Spider-Man we'll go through his
Adventure in the next video there is now
only one loose end the Enigma of Harry
Osborne Peter's best friend has been
here all along waiting in stasis as his
father searches for a cure I will find a
cure
I love you son
Venom is coming
thank you